the earliest event in the saw timeline
is the birth of John Kramer AKA jigsaw
in 1953 or 1954. we know this because at
the time of his death in 2006 they
mentioned his age subject's name is John
Kramer a 52 year old male caucasian over
the next 30 Years the saw timeline is
pretty uneventful other than the birth
of some major characters we don't have
exact dates for most of them but based
on their ages in the movies I'd estimate
that Lawrence Gordon was born in the
1950s and Mark Hoffman Eric Matthews and
Amanda young were born in the 1960s we
do know that Hoffman's sister Angelina
was born in 1971 or 1972 which we can
deduce from a newspaper article showing
that she was 25 at the time of her death
in 1997. then there's Logan Nelson born
August 18 1973 and Stephen sang born in
1975 or 1976 which we can do the math on
based on his age at the time of his
death in 2004. a raid that also resulted
in the death tap's partner 28 year old
Stephen Singh while the birth dates of
these characters aren't super important
to the story I found that I can use
similar logic to determine the dates of
almost everything that happens in the
series and create the ultimate timeline
that can help us better understand
everything about the saw lore and answer
questions that have always confronted
fans so if you want to know the date and
Order of events of everything in the
franchise stick around to the end of
this video thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
villain of the saw Saga is most known
for his puzzles in order to solve many
of his games and traps you have to put
together the puzzle pieces I even did a
character analysis episode where I put
together the pieces of jigsaw's Life
fittingly the saw timeline is also a
puzzle there are no title cards or
Graphics to display the dates and the
movies are known for their flashbacks
within flashbacks and non-linear
storytelling but there are Clues hidden
throughout about when certain things
take place if you want to know when Dr
Lawrence Gordon graduated from college
for example you'll have to zoom into his
diploma behind the desk June 4th 1979.
this has led many Saw fans to wonder
what if you put everything in
chronological order does the story still
work or will this create paradoxes and
contradictions after all if Dr Gordon
graduated when his diploma says he did
that makes him probably as old as John
Kramer what I found is that for the most
part the saw timeline is one of the most
well thought out and accurate horror
movie timelines out there there are a
few things that don't make sense but
most of them can be explained overall
the puzzle pieces actually fit together
really nicely and this was a really fun
puzzle to solve I know the saw fans have
been asking for this ever since I put
together a timeline for my Horror
history episodes a few years ago since
then I've noticed some things and made
this timeline even more accurate so
let's take it back to the next point of
importance in the saw Story the 1980s
[Music]
it would have likely been somewhere
around in 1983 when Adam stanheit who
would go on to be a photographer and one
of John Kramer's many victims got a
preview of that pain on his sixth
birthday on my sixth birthday my best
friend at the time Scott Tibbs stabbed
me with a rusty nail I didn't tell you
about that then there's the early career
of detective Mark Hoffman before
eventually going on to be jigsaw's first
successor he became a cop sometime in
the early 1980s I've been a cop for 20
years John Kramer himself went on to be
a civil engineer creating his first
building the Gideon meat packing plant
sometime in the mid to late 80s shortly
after this he teamed up with lawyer art
blank to start the urban renewal group
to create low-income housing one of
these homes is the location later known
as the nerve gas house meanwhile one of
Hoffman's earliest cases involved the
investigation of an abusive teacher with
his partner Daniel Rigg things escalate
and rig punches the teacher but avoids
charges because Hoffman lies on his
behalf don't get any ideas no punching
the Horror history Professor that is if
you want to live sometime around 1990
metropolitan police detective Eric
Matthews and his wife have a son named
Daniel we don't have any clues to his
date of birth other than the fact that
he seems to be around 15 years old
during the nerve gas house game in 2005.
around the time of Daniel's birth the
marital trouble start for Eric and his
wife likely due to Eric's infidelity
sometime in the early 90s Jon meets his
future wife Jill tuck Jill is a doctor
who works with recovering drug addicts
she starts her own practice called
Homeward Bound Clinic the movie Homeward
Bound was released in 1993 so one might
assume that Jill was trying to
capitalize off that popularity it makes
sense that this would also be around the
time that she founded the clinic which
was opened before she got pregnant in
1994. the Clinic's motto is cherish your
life a phrase that John would later
repeat to some of his victims no wonder
they were soul mates Jill holds a party
at her Clinic where John meets insurance
company Mogul William Easton John
doesn't like how William uses a formula
to determine who gets health coverage
and essentially who lives and dies John
isn't a psychopath yet so William avoids
going on his list for now we'll revisit
this the reason that we know all of this
takes place in the early 90s is because
John and Jill plan to have a baby in the
Chinese year of the pig John plots it
this way because the pig is a symbol of
rebirth which is Central to both work
the year of the pig occurs every 12
years meaning that these events occur in
either 1995 or 2007. Jon does not
survive to 2007 so it has to be 1995
meaning their son Gideon was likely
conceived in April 1994 nine months
before the Chinese New Year while Jill
is pregnant Jon becomes increasingly
concerned about her safety on the job
noticing some suspicious patients at her
Clinic specifically a man named Cecil
Adams who John one day had to convince
to put away his knife during an
altercation the incident foreshadows the
tragic night where everything changes in
November of 1994. we know this because
John states that Jill was seven months
pregnant at the time
foreign
Jill is locking up for the night Cecil
threatens her at knife point so that he
can steal some met he storms out and
slams the door into Jill's stomach
causing her to miscarry the loss of his
son devastates Jon sending him into a
dark depression where he distances
himself from his wife and his work
causing his marriage to slowly fall
apart on January 31st 1995 during the
previously mentioned year of the pig
celebration John donning a pig mask
kidnapped Cecil making him his first
victim just be glad he didn't choose ear
of the rooster I guess those masks are
strangely terrifying Cecil awakens in
John's Workshop where he takes part in
John's first trap the knife chair he
manages to escape that one but he tries
to retaliate Landing him in the razor
wire cage where he ultimately met his
fate this is where we first see Jon cut
a jigsaw piece out of Cecil's body which
would eventually earn him the nickname
jigsaw and Inspire the 1997 Will Smith
song getting jiggy with it all I can say
is it better be in Saw X Jill attempts
to give Jon another chance after months
of him distancing himself and joined by
Art blank she visits him at his workshop
at Gideon meat packing plant Jon
seemingly hasn't recovered at all and
kicks them out Jill tried to go back one
more time alone but didn't make any
progress and this was effectively the
end of their relationship I'm guessing
these were still both in early 1995
because when Jill goes the second time
there are still reconnaissance photos of
Cecil lying around we can also see at
this point he's already started working
on designing some of the famous traps
which he would use later on such as the
rack and the glass coffin these traps
almost never come to fruition though
shortly after Jill leaves him John is
diagnosed with cancer the combination of
a miscarriage divorce and cancer
diagnosis is too much for him to handle
and he decides to drive off a cliff and
end his life but Against All Odds he
survives and this near-death experience
makes him appreciate life in a way that
he never had before his faith in the
rehabilitation method he had tried and
failed on Cecil was restored this was
still nearly a decade before the events
of Saw but despite that there are still
a lot of events to unpack before that
fateful day when he put himself face
down on the bathroom floor
all of this talk of horror movie
timelines reminds me some of you who are
struggling may want to get the timeline
of your life back on track that's why
today's video is sponsored by better
help the online platform for
Professional Therapy it's secure
Professional Therapy online available
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room again
[Music]
foreign
facilitating therapeutic matches based
on your needs so they make it super easy
to change therapists if needed it's more
affordable because you're not paying for
the therapist's office space and they
even offer financial aid better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today just visit
betterhealth.comworld that's better
h-e-l-p for 10 off your first month
that's betterhelp.com cz's world for 10
off take charge of your mental health
now
foreign
over the course of the next five to
seven years so basically 1995 through
2002 John began to pay more attention to
the world around him as he continued to
receive chemotherapy for his colon
cancer he came to meet some of the other
people who he deemed as unappreciative
of their lives and planned to include
them in his upcoming test game he also
meets with his insurance provider
William Easton to request coverage for
an experimental cancer therapy in Norway
but his request is denied and this time
William is added to his list told you it
was coming back while jigsaw might
mostly be laying low for a while some
other notable events happen during this
time in 1995 or 1996 Dr Lawrence Gordon
and his wife give birth to a daughter
Diana Gordon which we know because she
was eight years old at the time of the
bathroom game during the home invasion
involving his wife and eight-year-old
daughter as previously stated in 1997
detective Hoffman's sister was murdered
by her boyfriend Seth Baxter during a
domestic dispute we can see this date on
a computer screen in sofa Hoffman does
not take this well and becomes an
alcoholic which in turn causes John
Kramer to take notice of him as someone
who is not cherishing life as you may
know court cases can take his as long as
a year to resolve sometimes and that's
exactly what happens here in 1998 Baxter
was sentenced to 25 years in prison
however he would be released early after
serving only five years in 2003 and 2003
minus five years is 1998 that's how I
know when he was sentenced rounding out
the Millennium with 1999 this was most
likely the year that Logan Nelson
graduated from medical school and began
his residency at the angel of Mercy
hospital where he would work under Dr
Gordon and cross paths with John Kramer
this is just me assuming that he went
straight through school and did not take
any breaks which I believe is typical
also in 1999 Hoffman saves the life of
fellow metropolitan police officer Matt
Gibson from a junkie during a distress
call at the old Crossroad Factory
Hoffman orders the perp to drop his gun
and he complies but Hoffman shoots him
anyway Hoffman thinks he's doing a favor
to Gibson but Gibson reports Hoffman for
brutality feels good to bring that one
out again about a year later in 2000
Hoffman gets promoted for saving
Gibson's life while Gibson gets
transferred to Internal Affairs where he
busted three of Hoffman's men a year
later I transferred to IA busted three
of his guys he swore he'd give me back
this is probably also around the time of
various police brutality incidents on
behalf of detective Eric Matthews what
brutality by 2003 John was deep into
planning his first game which would be a
test game held in private and just to
clarify a game is a test involving
multiple people and multiple traps while
a trap is a single test involving one or
more people he had found four
contestants for his game and he would
find his fifth before long when Logan
Nelson accidentally switched up his
x-rays with that of another patient
causing a delay in his treatment this
sealed Logan's fate as the fifth
contestant so in early 2003 John Kramer
held his barn game however Logan didn't
wake up in time for the beginning of the
game causing Jon to bail him out not
wanting Logan to die over an honest
mistake technically John Kramer's Barn
game could have taken place anywhere
between Jon's cancer diagnosis and
Logan's time in the military so I'm
putting it as late as possible on the
timeline due to the presence of advanced
technology after saving his life jigsaw
helps Logan rebound and Logan became his
first Apprentice together they created
the reverse bear trap after getting back
on his feet Logan served in the military
as a medic in lieutenants according to
his vial he shipped out in May of 2003.
there he served alongside Keith hunt me
too Nacho Logan was aromatic in Fallujah
it was also around this time in O3 that
jigsaw must have conducted his earliest
set of individual traps but these as far
as we know are never seen in any Saw
movie so how do I know that they happen
well this is right before Mark Hoffman
attempted to create his own copycat
jigsaw trap the pendulum the barn game
was never discovered by police so in
order for this copycat crime to make
sense there had to have been other
jigsaw traps that were discovered by
police in the first place even though we
don't see them on this list of Jigsaw
victims in saw five maybe there's
another page to this list that we don't
see or maybe they were also badly
mutilated that they could not be
identified there is actually further
proof of their existence though in 2016
Logan Nelson created some new jigsaw
audio by splicing together audio from
old's tapes this was before voice.ai he
splices in words that aren't from any of
the jigsaw tapes that we've seen in saw
one through seven the games have begun
again
they will not stop until the sins
against the innocent are atoned for I
will take care of the next four you take
care of the rest so this audio could
have come from the extra victims in 2003
which had to happen before May 2003 the
month that Seth Baxter was released from
prison on a technicality I know he was
released in May because at the scene of
his death in June a detective states
that he got out one month ago typical
bio murder convict surf five years just
released last month but it's easy how do
you know his death took place in June
well it's right here in the next day's
newspaper dated June 11 which would
probably come out the day after meaning
Hoffman plays Seth Baxter in the
pendulum trap on June 10th 2003. but CZ
how do you know it's 2003 and not 2004
because by 2004 Hoffman was already
helping jigsaw set up traps the pendulum
happened before Hoffman met jigsaw so it
has to be 2003. I really did my homework
this time obviously it's shortly after
the pendulum when Jon finds out about
the copycat crime and punches hopping
for it with a trap called the shotgun
check Hoffman is converted into a jigsaw
follower and would help out with with
future traps as John's physical
condition continues to weaken next up
June 2003 John Kramer was diagnosed with
an inoperable frontal lobe tumor we know
this because John's medical report dated
March 24 2004 has shown and the initial
diagnosis is said to be nine months
earlier so it's time for him to really
get to work he probably doesn't have
long to live and he's still got a lot of
people to rehabilitate in late February
2004 John with Hoffman's help kidnapped
Paul Leakey and places him in the razor
wire remains you are perfectly healthy
say a middle-class male good last month
he ran a street razor across your wrist
I'm no doctor but it doesn't seem to me
like Paul was a perfectly healthy and
sane individual as Paul bleeds to death
in the Trap John and Hoffman observed
through people this is also when John
tasks Hoffman was placing Dr Gordon's
pen light at the scene of the next trap
in order to throw off the police I'm
placing this in February 2004 because
it's three weeks before police found
Paul's body on March 19 2004. this one's
not fresh anymore
at least three weeks out the next
subject would be Mark Wilson who had to
contend with the flammable jelly trap
they chose Wilson because he was faking
an illness and this would be the one
where Hoffman Left Behind Dr Gordon's
pen lines I'm just kind of assuming that
both of these traps occurred before
police start finding stuff they first
find Paul on March 19th then Mark
shortly after that finding Dr Gordon's
pet John's Medical situation continues
to get worse on March 24 2004. he gets
more cancerous growth that affects his
ability to speak and move the right side
of his body but these ailments would not
stop him from overseeing his most iconic
trap yet
[Music]
in May 2004 John would bring in two more
Homeward Bound patients Amanda young and
Donnie Greco for his reverse bear trap
we know this date because Dr Gordon
cites that it was five months ago while
he's chained up in the bathroom in
October which I'll get to Amanda kills
Donnie and takes the key from his
stomach to unlock the Trap when Amanda
gets out she doesn't immediately go to
police because we can see her wounds
appeals a bit before that the detectives
soon bring in Dr Gordon for questioning
regarding his pen light at the crime
scene and Dr Gordon confesses his
whereabouts he was having an affair
immediately after they interrogate
Amanda who praises jigsaw for his
Rehabilitation method when she gets home
after everything John is there waiting
for her he takes her under his wing and
brings her into Jill's Clinic as
evidence that his methods can turn a
person's life around in ways that Jill's
Medical Treatments could not Amanda was
proud to have recovered from her
addiction even after Jill had given up
on her it works
he helped me I'm sticking all these
scenes together in the timeline because
of the continuity with Jon being bald as
he prepares for the bathroom game and
Amanda's clothing and hair other events
that summer include detective sing and
tap finding jigsaw's workshop on stygian
Street only to discover it was a trap
for them Taft gets his throat slashed
but lives Singh isn't so lucky and he's
killed in the shotgun trap tap is
discharged from the police force on June
21st according to these signatures but
he becomes obsessed and decides to take
the investigation into his own hands
renting an apartment across from Dr
Gordon and hiring a photographer named
Adam to keep tabs on him this is all
part of the five months in between the
reverse bear trap and the bathroom game
as I mentioned before the bathroom game
would be held in October 2004. funny
story when I first started developing I
saw a timeline a few years ago I began
by putting the bathroom game in October
2004 just as a placeholder because
that's when the original saw came out
and I built everything around that
luckily it ended up working perfectly in
relation to all of the other dates and I
discovered that I got to keep it there
the movie came out October 29th so
although it's not a Canon date I like to
imagine that that's when the bathroom
game took place before everything goes
in motion and Jon performs a rebirth
ceremony his own version of a baptism
asking Amanda to give everything to him
and deciding her her first task as a
jigsaw disciple to go kidnap Adam so
Adam is kidnapped by Amanda Dr Gordon is
kidnapped by someone I don't think we
actually know and they are chained up in
the dilapidated bathroom underneath the
nerve gas house before the two
contestants wake up John and Amanda put
the finishing touches on the game with
John staging himself as a dead man in
the middle of the floor and Amanda
putting Adam into place in the bathtub
when Adam and Lawrence wake up they
discover the instructions Gordon is
supposed to kill Adam and Adam is simply
meant to escape neither one of them ends
up succeeding but Dr Gordon does
demonstrate his will to survive by
cutting off his foot in order to try to
get away so before he can fully Escape
Jon catches up congratulates him on
Surviving and convinces him to become a
jigsaw Apprentice in the following days
Amanda feels guilty about Adam and
returns to the bathroom to mercy kill
him by suffocating him with a plastic
bag Adam would have starved to death
before too long so that's got to be late
October or early November not long after
that there's some activity overseas
Logan is still serving in the military
and partakes in the Second Battle of
Fallujah this isn't shown in the movies
but it's a real battle that took place
in November and December of 2004. you
got a character but not before taking
out three Taliban
um what I heard they tortured this [__]
out Gordon soon leaves his position at
the angel of Mercy Hospital to work at
St Eustis Hospital presumably to
distance himself from his co-workers who
would soon become jigsaw victims after
the bathroom game jigsaw continues
carrying out smaller traps one of these
which must have been in late 2004 or
early 2005 involved a woman named Joan
who went on television to tell her story
this inspires a man named Bobby Degan to
pretend to be a jigsaw victim and write
a book called survive which becomes a
huge hit John doesn't like the fact that
Dagan is lying about becoming one of his
victims so he confronts him at a book
signing in fact this must be 2005
entirely based on the fact that John
Kramer is swearing a backwards hat at
the age of 51. or maybe the backwards
hat is to indicate that he's a rebel and
he would soon demonstrate that remember
how his healthcare insurance provider
told him he couldn't seek outside
treatment he goes ahead and does it
Anyway by seeking out that Norwegian
doctor Dr Cecilia Peterson she has a
program outside Mexico City after going
through an operation scans revealed that
the tumor was never removed they only
pretended to cure him Jon puts each of
the people involved in the scam for
through a new game Amanda young also
seems to be involved also sometime in
2005 detective Eric Matthews files for
divorce from his wife which greatly
harms his relationship with his son who
begins to act out by stealing and
getting in trouble with the law Matthews
is also investigated by Internal Affairs
around this time for various incidents
of say it with me one two three and
speaking of which we get more Logan
Nelson updates according to his file
he's released by Saddam Hussein
loyalists in May of 2005. then in July
he returns from the military and goes
into treatment for his PTSD for the next
23 months in October a documentary
called full disclosure report piecing
together jigsaw airs on TV hosted by the
amazing and incredible Rich Skidmore it
goes over the mysteries of what happened
the previous year and exposes the Dark
Side of Eric Matthews we know this
program airs in October because of this
line on a chilly night one year ago each
mysteriously vanished some will try to
say that full disclosure report is not
canon because the name's Paul stahlberg
and Mark Rodriguez don't match up with
their real names Paul Leahy and Mark
Wilson but don't listen to them this
could be because middle names or
pseudonyms are used for privacy reasons
in the documentary don't you ever let
anyone discredit Rich Skidmore anyway
that leads right up to the beginning of
the next major game the nerve gas house
game Hoffman helps John kidnap the test
subjects and set them up in the house
all of these victims are people who
detective Matthew sent to prison by
faking evidence except for his son
Daniel Amanda is also in the game and
she's secretly a facilitator each
participant learns that they're
breathing in a poisonous gas and must
solve puzzles around the house to win
antidotes by now you're probably
screaming at the video wondering how I
know the date of the nerve gas house
game well we know the date of Saw 4 it's
in April 2006 and we know that the nerve
gas house in saw two was six months
earlier Eric's been missing for six
months this date also lines up really
nicely with the decomposition of the
bodies from the bathroom game the last
few contestants of the nerve gas game
end up discovering the bathroom at the
end and Adam and Zepp are still there I
consulted a forensic subreddit providing
photos of the corpses and a forensic
chem undergrad estimated that Adam had
been riding for one to two years so
everything lines up nicely anyway it
ends with a man Amanda saving Daniel
with the antidote and transporting him
to the Wilson steel plant where he's
kept safe the entire game was recorded
on security cameras the next day Dr
Gordon helps Jon by performing surgery
on police informant Michael marks Gordon
stitches a key behind his eye and this
is the key to unlock the Venus Fly death
trap mask sounds like it should be the
name of a metal band Michael is unable
to get the key so the mask clamps down
on his face and that's the end of
Michael marks detectives show up to the
crime scene where there's a clue for
Eric Matthews leading him to find the
location of jigsaw's Hideout the Wilson
steel plant and when they arrive Eric
and his team see the footage of the
nerve gas house game thinking that it
was being broadcast live while the
signal is traced Matthews tries to get
answers from jigsaw and grows
increasingly impatient which eventually
turns to violence this is not good for
Eric because this is actually his test
and he's failed so jigsaw agrees to take
him to the nerve gas house where he's
Sedated by Amanda and he wakes up with a
chain around his ankle just like Dr
Gordon and Adam a year earlier but
unlike Adam and Gordon Matthews finds a
way to escape without sawing off an
appendage it involves him breaking the
bones in his foot once he escapes he's
confronted by Amanda and she's not happy
about his survival
[Music]
after a ruthless fight with the hobbled
and broken detective Matthews Amanda
gets the upper hand and leaves him for
diet however someone presumably John
Kramer or Hoffman ends up saving him and
holding him captive in a Cell where his
only friend is this rat
however Matthews did have someone
looking for him on the outside Scott
Tibbs a mentally insane Pro jigsaw
wannabe rocker tries to make his own
documentary on jigsaw he makes it to the
press conference following Jon's escape
from Wilson steel plant and interviews a
detective Jenkins about the incident he
tries to visit Daniel Matthews in the
hospital but gets kicked out ironically
Daniel is a fan and probably would have
liked to visit from him then he tries to
spread the word about jigsaw which
doesn't work so he makes his own jigsaw
trap and tries to test it on himself and
nothing of value was lost that day and
that's the Scott Tibbs documentary an
often forgotten footnote in salor
obviously he wasn't the only one looking
for answers police were hard at work to
locate one of their own they kept
jigsaw's true identity under wraps for a
month until November 30th 2005 when it
went public and was published in the
Metro Gazette newspaper I'd assume that
after a month of searching with no
answers this was a desperate attempt to
find Matthews meanwhile back in John's
Camp Mr Kramer knew that his days were
numbered and asked Dr Gordon to
recommend him a brain surgeon to buy him
a little more time Gordon recommends Dr
Lynn denlin who was perfect because she
had ties to John's next big game the
calendar rolled over to 2006 but while
the rest of us were distracted by bird
flu and this trendy little new site
called YouTube John was planning his
most complex games yet he knew there was
a good chance that he wouldn't survive
this time around so he recorded the tape
for Jill expressing his regret about how
things ended you can tell it was made in
the operating room from Saw 3 while Jon
still has his hair but does not still
have the bruises given to him by
Matthews meaning that this must have
been recorded not long before he died
with jigsaw's true identity out in the
open Police test often with
interrogating Jill tuck Kramer who is
represented by John's former business
partner art blank blank is soon abducted
and forced into a trap called the
mausoleum trap with a man named Trevor
Dr Gordon once again helped set this up
stitching Trevor's eyes shut and Art's
mouth closed Trevor dies and blank
survives but blank is forced to wear a
device that'll sever his spine if he
doesn't obey orders this would come into
play shortly this time there would be a
few individual traps before the next big
game detective Hoffman and the now
promoted detective Kerry investigate the
aftermath of the classroom trap a trap
set by Amanda and Riggs to be
inescapable this leads to Amanda
kidnapping detective Carrie and setting
her up in another inescapable track the
angel trip Kerry's life is cut short in
the angel trap on April 24th 2006. four
days before she is discovered during the
events of Saw 3 and 4. Kerry was gone
for four days which means that it's
April 28th when she has finally
discovered this date was one of the
trickiest to determine because at the
end of Saw 4 we find out that the third
and fourth movies took place
simultaneously these will be known as
the Gideon games because the conclusion
of both games takes place at Gideon Mead
packing planets and in the fourth movie
there's a forensics report matching
officer Daniel Riggs fingerprints to a
bullet found at the crime scene that day
the report is labeled April 28th and
this would be an anchor point for a lot
of events such as Hoffman meets FBI
agents Perez and Strom at the site of
the Angel trap and they take over the
investigation looking for the accomplice
that the homicide department couldn't
find just hours before the Gideon games
Hoffman sets up Timothy young in the
rack Jon gives him some engineering tips
and Amanda taunts him asking when his
test will be
I'm not going anywhere you sure about
that John and Amanda then run into Jill
who begs John to stop what he's doing
John promises a way out for her when
it's all over he gives her a key
necklace telling her she'll know what to
do with it when the time is right then
we can also assume Hoffman moved Eric
Matthews out of his cell and onto a
block of ice at Gideon Mead packing
plants this isn't shown but it had to
have been hit he also leaves a note for
Amanda letting her know that he's aware
that she had something to do with the
death of Gideon and John and Jill's
miscarried son their rivalry intensifies
finally he visits jigsaw one last time
in the operating room and receives
instructions for a future game which
would eventually be known as the trial
of the Fatal Five jigsaw was ensuring
that his legacy would live on without
him with that Hoffman goes to the other
room and pretends to tie himself up next
to Eric Matthews while Amanda goes off
to abducts Dr Lynn denlin so that she
can perform the surgery on John the
simultaneous Gideon games involve two
main trials the trial of Jeff denlin
Lynn's husband who never learned to move
on after the death of their son and the
trial of Daniel Rigg a SWAT officer
whose obsession with saving those around
him prevents him from Living his own
life this is also secretly a test for
Amanda to to see if she can control her
anger seeing as how she's just been
killing victims for the last couple
traps now and not really giving them a
chance to survive at one point Amanda
probably realizing that she'll fail
warns Lynn and Jeff's daughter not to
trust the one who saves her which she
knew would be Hoffman this was Amanda's
way of getting revenge on Hoffman as
this message would make it back to the
FBI and would be their first indicator
that Hoffman could be corrupt anyway
just like all of the Chicago Bears head
coaches in my lifetime literally
everyone fails Amanda Jeff Lynne Rigg
Matthews art and several less important
characters all end up dead as does the
man himself jigsaw but you already knew
that we literally started the video by
saying he dies in 2006. the only
meaningful Survivor is Hoffman when the
FBI agent Strom comes snooping Hoffman
fittingly wearing a pig mask sneaks up
behind him and gives him the old needle
and puts him into the water Cube trap as
predicted by Amanda Hoffman saves Lynn
and Jeff's daughter and his hail is a
hero however he's shocked to find out
that Strom survived his trap as well
Strom had used a pen to poke a hole in
his trachea apparently allowing him to
breathe through his neck Shoulda filled
it with milk Hoffman Ricky mistake and
speaking of mistakes there's definitely
one here in the timeline during the
autopsy of John Kramer an autopsy is
usually performed the next day after a
death and thanks to strawman Hoffman
being collected by ambulances they would
have found Kramer in the other bodies
immediately so one would assume that
Jon's autopsy would occur the next day
April 29 2006 right the problem is that
the date on John's autopsy tag is
October 21st 2006. see it's right there
it doesn't take six months to do an
autopsy and judging by the lack of
decomposition on John's body it hasn't
been very long since he died so that
means one of these death dates April
28th or October 21st has got to be wrong
and all we can do is speculate on which
one obviously I think this one is wrong
and John's death was in April here's my
Russian we later see Hoffman looking at
evidence bags containing strom's cell
phone and the pen he used to poke the
hole in his neck those give us a month
and a day when the evidence was
collected May 7th and the day that the
evidence was moved to storage which
appears to be July 7th so if the
evidence was collected on May 7th that
means they were selecting evidence from
the warehouse for the next nine days
after the game games so the October 21st
tag doesn't make any sense maybe Logan
Nelson's cousin was in charge of putting
the tags on and uh just put the wrong
date or something in the meantime John's
executor calls up Jill and shows her the
final video recording that John left for
her and gives her this box this could
have taken place anywhere from May 8th
2006 to sometime in July 2006. all we
know is that an Executor must wait at
least 10 days before probating the will
in New Jersey where these movies take
place and when we next see Hoffman it
must be July 2006 because this is the
same day that we see the evidence bag
which says that the evidence was moved
to storage on July 7th and this is
storage so July 7th is already in the
past there are a few things to note from
this time period Hoffman is promoted for
his heroics and FBI agent Perez is
pronounced dead from her injury
sustained during the Daniel rig trial
but in reality the bureau is faking her
death for her own safety soon they would
discover the true nature of what they're
up against John Kramer may be gone but
jigsaw lives forever through the work of
his followers
while Hoffman starts preparing the next
game he receives an anonymous letter
claiming to know who he really is this
letter was sent by Dr Lawrence Gordon
who Hoffman doesn't know about it so he
suspects it's from Special Agent Strom
who basically accuses him of Being John
Kramer's accomplice look at you
couple of scratches and a story about
how your arm straps broke jigsaw doesn't
make mistakes drama follows up on this
Theory by doing a deep investigation of
his own into Hoffman which is the
inspiration behind one of my favorite
letterbox reviews this movie is about a
detective figuring out the plots of Saw
3 and saw 4. in the meantime Hoffman
cuts the ribbon on the next major game
the trial of the Fatal Five these
subjects were all involved in allowing a
building fire to occur years ago and to
be covered up which furthered their own
careers at the expense of others their
tests were created for them to work
together in order to survive as this is
going on Hoffman makes contact with
special agent strom's Superior special
agent Ericsson or as I like to call him
Jay Jonah Erickson
[Laughter]
he starts to plant the seeds in
Erickson's head of Strom possibly being
jigsaw's other accomplice he sets things
up at the location where the Fatal 5
game is being held to make it look like
Strom was behind it all they're crap
crap crap Mega crap so after luring
Strom into a trap the glass coffin trap
his drama fails to follow directions and
gets crushed by the collapsing room
while Hoffman is carried to safety that
is where saw 5 ends
and saw six begins but timeline wise
we're staying right here in July 2006.
saw six would take place less than a
week later just this past week a new
so-called game was discovered with
grisly results if that's not enough
proof for you consider the fact that
Hoffman retrieves strom's hand and uses
it to place fingerprints at various
crime scenes like the next trap the
pound of Flesh trap if it were any
longer than a week later the hand would
already be starting to decompose at the
crime scene following the pound of Flesh
Jay Jonah Erickson admits that they
faked agent Perez's death so you know
those flowers that you never sent The
Grieving family don't bother V2 would
continue their investigation despite
Strom looking very guilty at this point
there were still a couple more games
that Jon wanted his followers to carry
out after his death remember his old
friend William Easton the health
insurance guy he was about to get his
comeuppance the instructions for this
game were originally in the hands of
Jill left behind in the box that he left
for her in as well but Hoffman shows up
at her practice and usurps control
because Hoffman is a megalomaniac so the
next game would be held at Rowan
Zoological Institute and feature William
Easton in being forced to make the same
kind of life or death decisions about
who will receive Health Care coverage
only now in person regarding his own
employees you know this one's going to
be spicy meanwhile in the background
Erickson and Perez discovered that the
knife used to cut the jigsaw piece from
the latest victim matches the knife used
to cut the jigsaw piece from Seth Baxter
but doesn't match any of the other
victims their suspicion of Hoffman
continues to grow as they learn that
strom's fingerprints were placed after
he was already dead and eventually they
de-scrambled the voice on the Seth
Baxter jigsaw tape revealing none other
than detective Mark Hoffman
Hoffman is forced to kill all three FBI
agents he burns down the field office
once again marking the place with
strom's fingerprints which I just
realized doesn't make that much sense
because you'd think the FBI will be able
to analyze the fingerprints again and
determined they were planted their
postmortem in the meantime Jill drops
off a tape at Dr Gordon's office at St
Eustis Hospital one of John's secret
final requests then she goes to the zoo
and places a copy of Hoffman's note to
Amanda essentially letting him know that
he's in trouble because there shouldn't
be anyone who knows about this when he
sits down in his chair Jill activates a
shock device he's incapacitated and she
puts him in a new reverse bear trap and
leaves him for dead Hoffman does manage
to escape but it still does some damage
dripping open his cheek which he
stitches back together in a new Hideout
later that week finally after spending
four straight movies in 2006 there is
another time skip Hoffman goes into
hiding for eight months not emerging
again until March 2007. this date is a
little easier to figure out during the
hunt for Hoffman one of the police
computers displays an email with the
date March 12 2007. most of Saw 7 takes
place the same day but there are a
couple of things that take place before
the first is the public execution trap
where two men caught in a love triangle
must decide who will be eliminated in
front of a live audience at a shopping
center this is an interesting one to
play Legend has it that this scene was
originally going to show Jon and Dr
Gordon spectating in the crowd this
would place it pretty far in the past
but since it's not in the movie I'll
assume it's meant to take place closer
to the rest of Saw 7 in early 2007.
looking at weather patterns I see people
wearing jackets and hats which would put
us closer to the other scenes like
Jill's dream where we see snow and Bobby
dagen's abduction where we see his
breath personally I'm placing the public
execution trap in March 2007. it also
makes sense there because Hoffman's
return would probably spark Jill to fear
for her life again and go seek
protection from Matt Gibson the internal
affairs detective from Hoffman's past if
we're putting the public execution trap
in March then we also have to put the
next scene Bobby Dagan's TV interview in
March as well after that we have the car
trap which is the same day as that March
12th email that I mentioned earlier so
the rest of the saw Saga is pretty easy
to place the car trap is designed to
bring retribution to a group of racists
Bobby Degan hosts a self-help group for
jigsaw survivors which is remarkable
just remarkable promotional
and after this Bobby is kidnapped and
placed in the clear Dawn Hospital gain
where he and his team are ironically
forced to survive a jigsaw game much
like Bobby claimed he had in his book
meanwhile through a series of Clues
Hoffman leads Matt Gibson to his Hideout
where emotion activated turret is
waiting for him and Hoffman finally gets
the Revenge he promised all those years
ago Hoffman hides inside of a body bag
to sneak his way into the police station
where he takes out many officers on
route to the last person he needs to get
revenge on Jill tuck he sets her up in
an old classic the reverse bear trap and
third time's a charm with that device
finally after seven movies we get to see
it tear someone's face apart from the
inside and it is so satisfying but
Hoffman is still on the lose he packs up
some money and guns so he can start a
new life and it blows up his hideout in
the air Hank but he's intercepted by
jigsaw's greatest asset Dr Lawrence
Gordon and two more unknown apprentices
in pig masks after sedating detective
Hoffman well I guess we can't call him
that anymore I assume he's fired but
after sedating Hoffman Gordon locks him
inside the bathroom yes that bathroom
but this time with no chance to escape
and for a while it was game over but
aren't you forgetting about someone one
month later conveniently missing out on
the whole bloody saw Saga Logan Nelson
would be released from his PTSD
treatment by Dr Perry but I would say
that he was anything but here
foreign
October 5th 2007 Logan Nelson was
awarded a Purple Heart an award given to
U.S military personnel who were wounded
or killed in battle for the next eight
years there are no jigsaw related
killings that we know about and things
would go back to normal but normal
doesn't necessarily mean quiet we don't
know exactly when but Logan got the job
as the medical examiner at St Peter's
Hospital from this position he would see
a lot of incompetence from the local
detective Brad Halloran criminals seem
to go free while many innocent people
ended up dead on Logan's table in 2009
on the south side of the city a new
metro police detective named Zeke Banks
was partnered with officer Peter
Dunleavy under a policy called article 8
cops had the power to do essentially
whatever they wanted in the name of
stopping crime which led to a lot of
corruption in the Force One Day Dunleavy
shot a witness who was planning to
testify against another officer just to
keep him quiet the victim's son William
Emerson witnessed the crime and came to
praise Zeke when he did the right thing
by reporting Dunleavy to Internal
Affairs I'm putting this in 2009 because
it's 12 years before the main events of
spiral in 2021. it's been 12 yes
yes cop I get a medal for it big [__]
deal well at one point the son William
Emerson says it's 15 years I've been
loyal to you it's just the first day we
met 15 years ago the day your partner
killed my father so it looks like
another error there but I'm gonna assume
it's 12 years because that's said more
often and also 15 years doesn't make
sense that would put the Dunleavy
incident in 2006 and we never saw any of
those characters during the saw Saga
Hoffman even claimed that he was the
last one left at one point in 2011 a
degenerate Gambler named Malcolm Neal
was partially responsible for the death
of his wife when people he owed money
broke into his home and slit Mrs Neil's
throat this put him in Logan's bad
Graces it must have happened in 2011
because it stated to be five years
before the main events of Jigsaw which
are most likely in 2016. Malcolm Neil I
remember that case his wife was murdered
five years ago Malcolm Neil probably
wasn't enough to convince Logan to hold
his own jigsaw game but what would
happen next would in 2014 Logan's wife
Christine Nelson was killed by a loose
meth addict named Edgar Monson not to be
confused with burnout Eddie Munson from
stranger things to make matters even
worse Munson was free because of a
failed conviction by detective Halloran
2014 is two years before the main events
of Jigsaw it's been two years since
Christine passed this was probably the
Tipping Point and Logan decided to
recreate John Kramer's Barn game to
punish Halloran and test himself to see
if he could be as good of a jigsaw as
his master so in 2016 he holds his own
which I'll call Logan Nelson's Barn gang
because what the [__] else would I call
it this is stated several times to be 10
years after John's death Kramer's been
dead for 10 years John Kramer's dead and
has been for 10 years this is a blood
sample a perp taken a decade ago there's
a bit of a contradiction when Nelson
says that Jon's original game which he
did as a secret test before all the
other games was 10 years ago jigsaw died
three years after John Cramer's Barn
game so they can't both be 10 years ago
it's likely that Nelson was generalizing
he was essentially saying this was all
about a decade ago or maybe his PTSD
from the war has really affected his
math skills actually we kind of know
that he's using the term 10 years ago
kind of loosely because he also says
this 10 years ago I came out of the war
a Broken Man except his file says that
he came out of the war in 2005. so
clearly Nelson is just clumping that
whole time period between 2003 and 2006
together in his mind anyway Nelson puts
three contestants in his version of the
barn game and deposits the bodies in
public for Halloran to find after each
death each of them is someone connected
to halloran's past cases he also ends up
framing Halloran by leaving the puzzle
pieces in his freezer and leading him to
the pig farm where the two of them would
be the final players and Halloran is
scared into confessing all of his dirty
police work which Logan gets an audio
recording of some will think it's jigsaw
some expect you you no one will suspect
me and with all the evidence he needs
Logan slices halloran's head into seven
pieces with this laser cutter device
could not be the only person to try to
hold his own jigsaw games however
William Emerson the boy who watched his
father fall to the corrupt police force
was grown up and wanted Revenge that
takes us to spiral where corrupt police
officers on the South Side Metro PD come
to find themselves one by one caught in
a series of traps I'm placing the
beginning of spiral on July 4th 2021.
the July 4th part is obvious it happens
during an American Independence Day
celebration my calculations on the year
are a little less scientific at one
point we see the file of detective Marv
Boswick and it says he was born on May 9
1981. the actor that played Marv Daniel
Petro yanevi was also born in 1981 and
he doesn't appear to be aged up or aged
down in makeup he's just playing his
actual 40 year old self also spiral came
out in 2021 so it's pretty easy to
assume that this is when it was set
anyway Marv is killed in the subway trap
on July 4. the next day is July 5th and
Zeke is forced to team up with rookie
detective William shank this is William
Emerson the new jigsaw but he changed
his name so that nobody would make the
connection as they delve deeper into the
case they uncover a dark web of
corruption within the police force and
more and more crooked cops are put into
jigsaw traps Zeke takes the lead on the
case they question boswick's morning
wife and during some late night research
another cop named Fitch is put into the
finger tree the next day is July 6.
Fitch's fingers are discovered at a
freeway underpass along with a new
message from the new jigsaw and the body
is later found at a bread factory Zeke
and shank investigate a drug dealer who
may have ties to the case and they
questioned Zeke's old partner done
leaving that night Zeke's father a
former cop also goes missing and our
last date on the timeline for now is
July 7th and I know I've been counting
correctly because we can see the date is
7-7 on a security camera fee shank
doesn't show up for work that day and
police receive a new package containing
skin with shank's tattoo a body is
discovered at a local butcher shop and
they assume that it's shank the police
chief is then attacked in the evidence
room and put into the wax trap Zeke
continues to search for his dad but he's
kidnapped by someone in a pig mask and
finds himself in a series of tests in an
abandoned soap Factory as you can
probably guess I'll refer to this as the
soap Factory game at the end he finds
shank alive and to his surprise shank
wants to team up with him his proposal
is for Zeke to help him find the dirty
cops and shank would give them jigsaw
style punishments he brings him to the
final test where Zeke finds his dad in
the IV drip trap Zeke must decide
between stopping shank or freeing his
dad in the end Zeke saves his dad but
shank has a backup plan when the SWAT
team cuts down the door it triggers a
machine that puppeteers Mr Banks to look
like a threats and they're all forced to
shoot him down in all of the commotion
shank gets away so there are now at
least three jigsaws running around out
there Dr Gordon Logan Nelson and William
Emerson aka William shank in the end
there was just one scene that I
absolutely couldn't place in Saw 7
during the Survivor support group we
meet a new survivor named Sydney who
tells about her experiences in the
lawnmower trap there's no indication of
when this happened but if I had to put
it somewhere I would put it in the first
quarter of 2006 before the classroom
trap or the angel trap maybe Amanda put
Sydney in the lawnmower trap and she was
frustrated when Sydney survived and
that's why she decided to make future
traps inescapable so that's the saw
timeline as it currently stands it's not
perfect by any means but there are
really only a few major contradictions
that can't be explained You could argue
that there shouldn't have been HDTVs in
some of the flashback scenes before HD
was popular but technically it was
possible I think after saw X there's
really no room in the timeline to do
anything with John Kramer but as Eleanor
so eloquently explained jigsaw lives
forever to the work of his followers so
it'll be interesting to see what happens
with our current surviving jigsaws and
who might take up the mantle next I've
got individual analysis episodes on each
of John Kramer's devoted followers as
well as some other saw characters you
can find them in that playlist on the
left for all things saw make sure you
subscribe to cz's world for new Horrors
every week ring the death bell for all
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive